bonjour à tous nous allons commencer ce
nouveau point presse par l'agenda
demain mardi 23 janvier aura lieu le
bureau politique
puis jeudi laurent wauquiez sera
l'invité de l'émission politique sur
france 2 samedi
nous nous réunissons à la mutualité pour
le conseil national
avec une matinée qui sera en huit lots
puis à partir de 13 heures les
journalistes seront conviés pour le
conseil national
alors pour débuter gilles va nous parler
du cannabis puis nous enchaînerons sur
sur le mouvement dans les prisons merci
lydia bonjour à toutes et à tous
quelques mots sur à sur le rapport de
mission parlementaires et les
expressions qui dans ce week-end sont
tombés sur sur le meilleur moyen de
lutter contre la propagation du cannabis
les républicains ne rentreront pas à ce
matin dans le sujet de savoir s'ils sont
ou non d'accord avec le rapport qui a
été édité et qui a été largement
commenté dans ce week-end
en revanche il nous semble important de
rappeler un certain nombre de points sur
lesquels nous souhaitons que la
réflexion s'engage puisque le parlement
sera visiblement saisi de cette question
dans les mois qui viennent les l'option
que nous défendons c'est celle de
la non dépénalisation de la consommation
du cannabis c'est évidemment une
opposition ferme contrairement à
d'autres mouvements politiques à la
légalisation de cette consommation
il nous semble nécessaire que l'on ne se
limite pas si la réflexion doit
s'engager à l'initiative du gouvernement
s'ils le souhaitent sur les moyens de
répression que la réflexion ne se limite
pas uniquement à à ses moyens de
répression mais également pour souligner
quels sont les axes de politique de
prévention qu'on peut développer dans ce
pays car il s'agit de rappeler que la
consommation de cannabis est dangereuse
pour la santé notamment pour les jeunes
et il y aurait une incompréhension des
françaises et des français que on les
oblige en est question de sécurité
publique abc leur vitesse de 10 km heure
sur des routes secondaires et qu'on
donne des signes de faiblesse dès lors
qu'il s'agit de lutter contre la
propension au développement de la
consommation de cannabis
ce sujet est un sujet sérieux c'est un
sujet de santé publique et les
républicains sont très attachés à ce que
ce débat soit posée comme tel et enfin
il nous semble que dans la mission
parlementaire et dans ceux qui
pourraient découler sur le plan des
propositions législatives
il manque un axe que romain reda
d'ailleurs à lui-même souligné
c'est la kz2 la lutte pour le
démantèlement des réseaux de trafiquants
car c'est une chose que de s'en prendre
aux consommateurs mais c'est un autre
sujet bien plus compliqué d'ailleurs que
de s'attaquer à des filières qui
prospère qui ont maintenant des moyens
de blanchir l'argent par des systèmes de
paiement qui sont dématérialisés et qui
pose un véritable souci en réalité pour
l'économie en général est la santé en
particulier
voilà ce que nous voulions rappeler sur
ce sujet qui fait l'actualité ce
week-end et qui est appelée à
la sphère encore dans les semaines et
les mois qui viennent j'ai laissé
maintenant l'apport à la lidia qui
souhaite également porter notre
expression sur une autre actualité celle
des prisons et du mouvement revendicatif
des gardiens en effet je te remercie
gilles rappelons que le cannabis est
tout de même une drogue et qu'en cela
elle a des conséquences très lourdes sur
la santé notamment de nos jeunes enfants
puisque la consommation concerne
maintenant un public de plus en plus
jeune et il faudrait avoir une politique
qui soit sur la prévention mais
également sur la répression pour pour
briser tous les trafics qui via dans les
quartiers c'est un véritable enjeu
également de société alors nous sommes
naturellement solidaires du mouvement
des gardiens de prison il exprime une
détresse et un désarroi que nous devons
entendre et auquel nous devons apporter
des réponses rapides
ce n'est pas ce n'est pas un phénomène
nouveau que ces agressions comme les
policiers qui sont victimes d'agressions
a régulièrement les gardiens de prison
sont également victimes de la montée de
la violence dans les prisons
nicole belloubet ne semble pas prendre
la mesure de cette détresse et de cette
urgence qu il qu'ils expriment les
réponses qui ont été apportées jusqu'à
maintenant semblent en deçà des enjeux
l'administration pénitentiaire est pour
le moment toujours le parent pauvre de
la justice et il faut des réponses très
rapide
notre système carcéral va mal et les
réponses ne semble pas vraiment à la
hauteur nous chez les républicains
nous demandons le rétablissement des
peines planchers et nous avons lancé une
pétition pour que les peines plancher
soit rétabli pour tous tpt agression qui
soit contre une personne qu'ils soient
détenteurs de l'autorité publique
la police les gendarmes les gardiens de
prison mais également les pompiers il
faut que la peur change de camp dans ce
domaine et nous demandons également à ce
que le plan de construction de places de
prison soit relancé il avait été
freinés durant le quinquennat de
françois hollande emmanuel macron et son
gouvernement ne semble pas non plus prêt
à relancer un plan ambitieux de
construction de places de prison
plus de places de prison c'est permettre
à ce que la surpopulation carcérale
diminue c'est permettre aussi des
meilleures conditions de travail pour
les gardiens de prison avec un meilleur
équipement est également pouvoir dédier
des ailes dans les prisons pour les
détenus radicaliser car le problème
aujourd'hui comme dans l'ensemble de la
société française c'est la montée en
puissance de la violence lié à
l'islamisme radical et des personnes qui
sont radicalisés et prêtes à s'en
prendre que ce soit aux gardiens de
prison aux policiers ou aux citoyens
français
donc nous attendons vraiment des
propositions beaucoup plus ambitieuse et
nous sommes aux côtés des des gardiens
de prison et 2 et nous comprenons leur
détresse est-ce que vous avez des
questions
on a appris hier dans le jdd que
organise un référendum enfin passer la
réforme constitutionnelle qu'est ce que
vous en dites
effectivement c'est une option qui
semble-t-il a été agitée par des cercles
élyséen en tout cas des membres de la
majorité
je trouve et nous trouvons assez
irrespectueux que alors même que le
débat n'a pas encore eu lieu entre les
deux chambres du parlement ont brandi ce
déjà une menace qu'ils soient une menace
référendaire j'aimerais rappeler
qu'effectivement c'est un une option qui
est dans la main du président de la
république mais nous avait semblé
comprendre peut-être avions-nous mal
compris que il souhaitait d'abord que le
parlement que ça intéresse un tout petit
peu que de connaître et de discuter
l'essence même de cette réforme devait
être associée que tous les moyens de
mettre m mise en oeuvre pour que l'on
puisse aboutir à un consensus sur cette
question
or brandir aujourd'hui l'option du
référendum
c'est un autre sens mettre une pression
sur des discussions qui doivent pourtant
se dérouler il nous semblerait que ce
serait la mauvaise méthode nous espérons
simplement que c'est un dans un premier
temps un moyen qui sera écartée parce
que ça serait en contradiction avec les
intentions manifestées par le
gouvernement et par le président de la
république jusqu alors donc nous
souhaitons d'abord que la voie du
dialogue entre les assemblées soit celle
qu'ils soient privilégiés et qu'elles
aboutissent nous souhaitons parce que le
sénat c'est bien cela dont il est
question
le sénat dont visiblement le président
n'a publics craint l'expression a
néanmoins un mot éminent à dire il est
dans le cadre des équilibres
institutionnels à un interlocuteur
incontournable et nous ne souhaitons pas
qu'on cherche dans un premier temps
comme on le laisse entendre maintenant à
le contourner ce qui serait une offense
faite au cadre démocratique
dirigeants grandes entreprises pour
séduire ses dirigeants de
multinationales qu'elles
quel regard vous avez là dessus voilà
versailles à nouveau effectivement
emmanuel macron reçoit à versailles
plusieurs dirigeants de grandes
entreprises ce que nous attendons c'est
que c'est dirigeants investissent en
france parce que il est certes la
compétitivité française temps à
reprendre mais cela est dû plutôt à une
conjoncture internationale et nous
souhaitons que ces entreprises
aujourd'hui investissent concrètement en
france et nous souhaitons également qui
est une véritable politique de
réindustrialisation de la france parce
que voilà il ya il ya un problème avec
l'industrie en france et industrie nous
quitte et ça crée des problèmes d'emploi
notamment le chômage de long terme donc
voila nous c'est très bien de recevoir
ces entreprises mais nous voulons de
véritables investissements
vous étiez intéressé sur le symbole même
du lieu c'est vrai que si l'objectif est
louable la méthode interroge on a
l'impression que le président de
république prend beaucoup de plaisir à
se lever dans le cadre du roi soleil
après avoir marché depuis la cour carrée
du louvre le soir de sa victoire après
avoir fêté ses 40 ans à chambord le
voici de retour à versailles
nous souhaiterions bien évidemment puis
en tirant une légitime fierté de notre
patrimoine national et dans un souci de
continuité historique a toujours été
celui de notre famille politique
rappeler qu'il y à aussi de beaulieu
républicains qui sont également des
marqueurs pour l'innovation française y
compris au regard du monde
je dis ça pour l'anecdote on est bien
d'accord que ce qui nous importe ça
n'est pas tant le lieu que le résultat
qu'on en tirera et savoir en particulier
si on essaie on essaie de confirmer
cette tendance à à ces marqueurs monde
de l'économie mondiale
pas simplement française qui semble
plutôt ouvert mais nous souhaiterions
surtout que la france se met en mesure
d'en tirer tous les profits il y a
encore beaucoup de travail pour réformer
notre économie dans ce sens
le premier ministre reçoit les
dirigeants de la collectivité de corse
aujourd'hui quelle est la position du
parti égard aux revendications des
nationalistes alors pour le moment nous
sommes dans une position d'attenté
vis-à-vis des négociations qui ont
commencé entre le gouvernement et les
représentants du territoire corse
nous voudrions simplement rappeler à ce
stade de ce dossier l'attachement des
républicains aux cadres constitutionnels
français qui est un cadre prenant
l'unité et l'indivisibilité de la
république et un certain nombre de
réalités constitutionnel notamment
celles qui figurent au titre ii du
français seule langue de la république
française donc nous sommes évidemment
désireux est curieux de voir comment le
gouvernement va s'attaquer à ce problème
est vrai une offense à un avis général
des républicains si j'en disais plus
aujourd'hui donc nous sommes dans une
position d'attenté
mais qu'il soit bien clair c'est une
attente très vigilants vis-à-vis des
principes que je viens de rappeler
beaucoup et à la semaine prochaine